thank you
thank you so much all right here we go
thank you hello jack you just got here
in a way yeah okay
you get the scores yet you get the
scores you head to the game
okay feel free to talk to me at any time
Big Daddy it just me and you
Jack you know you're Babe Ruth to me I
know I understand okay
it's a four-hour show win fair out with
that Jack Jack has three Oscars which is
no big deal so so to some guy in Belle
calmly on the private I'll be back - all
right Oscar is 72 and what'd he give to
the guy who's got everything how about
these three beautiful women Cameron Diaz
Lucy Liu and drew Barrymore
don't have the best job in the whole
world you girls we're actresses you get
to go to work every day put on costumes
tonight we get to put on gown yes how
many gowns did you try on drew um I had
this one made you did yeah yeah I'll
hear about it tomorrow I'm sure I had
this one me yeah oh you guys thank you
what guys
oh right okay okay hi we're here to
present the award for best achievement
in costume design here are the nominees
Jenny Beavan for Anna and the king
Colleen Atwood for Sleepy Hollow
and Roth and Gary Jones for the talented
mr. Ripley
Malena cannon arrow for Titus
and Lindy hemming or topsy turvy
and the Oscar goes to rehearsal only
Lindy hemming for topsy turvy
this is Lindy Hemmings first Oscar
nomination
you
thank you I'd like to thank Mike Lee and
Simon trailing Williams and all the
people who work with me to make such
beautiful costumes and I'd like to thank
all of you for giving our little film
such a brilliant start thank you
stay tuned for Haley Joel Osment Mike
Hyers Heather Graham and the Oscar for
Best Supporting Actress right after
these messages